con nuestro segundo invitado del día
vamos a hablar de la situación
migratoria de todas las personas que
quieren Ingresar a Estados Unidos
afectadas por las nuevas políticas del
gobierno del presidente Joe biden en
cuestión de migración haitianos cubanos
nicaragüenses y venezolanos
ensucialidades las nacionalidades más
afectadas por esta decisión solo Vamos a
Tiziano breda él es investigador para el
Instituto afari internacional Gracias
Tiziano por estar con nosotros en
directo América de France 24 y le
pregunto primeramente Cómo afecta esta
decisión del gobierno de Joe biden de
devolver automáticamente a México a los
migrantes de estas cuatro nacionalidades
de las cuales estábamos hablando
anteriormente
Buenos días Raúl Muchas gracias por la
invitación efectivamente
Esta es una medida que
demuestra como la priorización en las
políticas migratorias de biden en este
momento pues siga un poco la la presión
actual que se está dando en la frontera
Sur precisamente después de haber tomado
esta medida con digamos en relación con
los venezolanos que representaban un una
porción muy grande de los de las
llegadas en hace unos meses en la
frontera sur de Estados Unidos pues se
aplica esta otra nacionalidades que
también han crecido mucho en el volumen
de llegadas Pero al final de cuentas por
mucho que la razón digamos la
explicación sea en papel correcta de la
de Buscar maneras más reguladas y
formales de entrar a Estados Unidos para
buscar un empleo o para poder pedir
asilo en realidad
me parecería que claramente la esperanza
el objetivo es la de disminuir las
llegadas a la frontera Sur como también
pues es la explicación por la expansión
de este programa mismo que vayan entre
las justificaciones dice los venezolanos
están llegando muchos mil por día si no
estoy mal ahorita están llegando en 200
250 por día claro además Tiziano estas
dificultades el que tienen los migrantes
para cumplir todas estas políticas
migratorias de Joe biden por ejemplo
llegar en aviones eso ya pues acarrea
evidentemente en un gasto de un tiquete
aéreo también tener una persona que se
haga responsable por ese migrante que
quiere ir a Estados Unidos que ya sea
que tenga un estatus legal en ese en ese
país no económicamente estas personas
evidentemente no tienen Pues todos estos
recursos para poder hacer esta migración
organizada Y qué va a pasar porque y sin
embargo a pesar de estas políticas
Tiziano los migrantes Todavía siguen
intentando ingresar por la frontera sur
de Estados Unidos no esto se va a
disminuir esto se ha disminuido o o sin
embargo los migrantes igual van a querer
intentarlo siempre
Pues la verdad yo tuve la oportunidad de
hablar con los venezolanos cuando
todavía residía en Guatemala y estaban
de tránsito efectivamente esta medida
que se dio el año pasado que consenía a
ellos en un primer momento pues se leyó
como una un cierre de la frontera
básicamente un emprendimiento muy fuerte
para llegar y
empujaba muchos a dejar digamos de
emprender ese camino incluso a regresar
hacia el Darién no en Panamá esta esta
selva muy peligrosa que Habían intentado
cruzar para para subir hacia el norte
pero después de un tiempo al quedarse
varados básicamente en países en donde
No necesariamente digamos no no es no es
en sus objetivos quedarse muchos se han
visto obligados De todas formas a buscar
como como llegar a Estados Unidos a
pesar de riesgo de ser detenido o
deportados Entonces yo creo que podría
ser parecida la la dinámica para muchos
porque al final de cuentas
la mayoría de los de los migrantes y
solicitantes de ácido pues buscan
Estados Unidos como como su destino
final Entonces
es bueno aumentar las maneras legales de
llegar pero claramente para una la
mayoría la inmensa mayoría de los
migrantes es difícil acceder a un
patrocinador desde afuera
y e incluso Pues en algunos casos
acceder a el uso de un teléfono celular
para poder descargar la aplicación y
hacer todos esos trámites en línea y por
lo tanto creo que sea difícil que al
final de cuentas pues esto constituía
una una solución para el mediano y largo
plazo Claro
sin embargo estos países siguen tomando
medidas a no tras la reunión de los
líderes de los países del Norte hablamos
de Andrés Manuel López Obrador de México
de ca ellos vayan en Estados Unidos esta
reunión que se hizo en Ciudad de México
el lunes y martes ellos decidieron crear
entonces un centro para recibir a estos
migrantes en el sur de México con el
apoyo económico de Canadá y también de
Estados Unidos esta medida digamos este
tipo de medidas es suficiente y que otro
tipo de medidas son necesarias para
poder mitigar esta situación que los
migrantes tengan todo el apoyo necesario
bien sea para seguir su camino hacia
donde quisieran llegar o para devolverse
a sus países de origen
pues crear estos centros a mí me parece
que no más podría
crear mayores cuellos de botellas
básicamente en en el camino de muchos
migrantes hacia hacia el norte O sea no
creo que exista un centro que pueda
acoger a cientos de miles de inmigrantes
que que cada año básicamente intentan
cruzar la frontera
hacia Estados Unidos me parecería que
sería mejor trabajar en potenciar los
servicios que se les puedan ofrecer
servicios de las embajadas por ejemplo o
de en cooperación con la con las
agencias migratorias de los diferentes
países en la ruta Incluso en
Centroamérica
[Música]
para precisamente pues aumentar las las
posibilidades de que alguien busca una
manera de llegar a Estados Unidos sin
toda la travesía sin tener que recorrer
todo el camino para para llegar hacia el
norte que sabemos que es muy peligroso
Pues que alimenta economías ilícitas de
grupos ilegales incluso ligados al
narcotráfico
y claramente esto implica colaborar o
Buscar digamos acercamientos con
gobiernos con los cuales pues ha habido
muchas tensiones en los últimos años
diría yo por los retrocesos democráticos
que han ocurrido en esos países y y por
lo tanto que han chocado con algunas de
las de las prioridades sí que la
administración biden ha dado hacia la
región como la lucha contra la
corrupción etcétera y por lo tanto creo
que es parte de la razón por la cual
estos países me refiero a Guatemala El
Salvador Honduras por ejemplo
no están siendo parte de la conversación
sino más digamos desde el punto de vista
de Buscar inversión para crear
oportunidades y así evitar que la gente
quiera o sienta la exigencia de migrar